[موسيقى]
مساء الخير مشاهدينا انا ميسون واهد وقدم
لكم اخبار الساعه وطبعا سنتابع والعنوان
الرئيسي هو اقتحام القوات الاسرائيليه
للمسجد الاقصى باستخدام الرصاص المطاطي
وقنابل الغاز وجلسه طارئه لمجلس الامن غدا
موسكو تتهم الغرب بفتح جبهه جديده ضدها من
جورجيا واشنطن تؤكد استمرارها بدعم كاف
ترامب يطالب الجمهوريين في الكونغرس
بالغاء تمويل وزاره العدل ومكتب التحقيقات
الفيدراليه
وباريس تقود انفتاحا اوروبيا على الصين
دعم الوساطه في اوكرانيا وضمان وديمومه
العلاقات التجاريه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وان
ارفع ومشاهدينا طبعا اهلا بكم الى اخبار
الساعه التي نبداها من تطورات الساعه
تحديدا في القدس حيث اقتحمت القوات
الاسرائيليه باحات المسجد الاقصى لمنع
المصلين من الاعتكافله الثانيه على
التوالي القوات الاسرائيليه استخدمت
الرصاصه المطاطي وقنابل الغاز ضد المصلين
في الاقصى فيما افاد مراسل العربيه
بمحاصره القوات الاسرائيليه لمحيط المصلى
القبلي في المسجد
وطبعا سنتابع ما يجري في المسجد الاقصى
ينضم اليه الان دكتور امجد شهاب ناشط
مقدسيه دكتور امجد انت كنت موجود في
المسجد الاقصى والان خرجت هل يمكن ان تصف
لنا ماذا حصل بالضبط وكيف هو الوضع الان
شكرا على الاستضافه
ما حدث كان متوقعا كان متوقعا لان هناك
فرد للقوانين الاسرائيليه بان هناك رفض
تام لعمليه الاعتكاف وقد وقد صرحوا بانهم
يرفضون تماما الاعتكاف في الايام التي تلي
عمليات اقتحامات المستوطنين وسمحوا في
الاعتكاف فقط في ايام الخميس والجمعه لان
المستوطنين لا يدخلون لباحات المسجد
الاقصى ايام الجمعه والسبت
والفلسطينيين حاولوا تحدي هذا هذا هذه
القرارات
بمحاوله مره اخرى
للاعتكاف في داخل بحات المسجد القبلي
وقامت القوات الاسرائيليه قبل قليل قبل
نهايه الصلاه بعمليه اقتحام حتى تتجنب
اغلاق الابواب ودخلوا الى الى الى داخل
المسجد القبلي واخرجوا جميع المصلين حتى
حتى يت وجود عدد من المعتكفين وقد يؤدي
ذلك عندما يدخل المستوطنين في اليوم
التالي وهو اليوم الثاني لما يسمى بعيد
الفصح اليهودي بازعاج المستوطنين
واستطاعوا كما فعلوا البارحه
بافراغ بحات المسجد الاقصى طبعا هذه هذه
تدخل في نطاق البرنامج برنامج الحكومه
الاسرائيليه والتفاهمات التي التي ادت الى
هذا التحالف
بناهم يبحثون عن هدف اساسي وهو الوصول الى
الى تقسيم المكاني بعد ان قاموا بالتقسيم
الزماني منذ سنوات طويله هم يريدون ان
يحققوا اي انجازات محاولات الفلسطينيين
بالاعتكاف يعتبرون انها تحدي لهم
وقد قاموا بذلك
لفرض السياده الكامله وهم يحولون بطريقه
اخرى نزع كل صلاحيات الاوقاف او حتى
انشاء نجمه نجمه دينيه لاداره طبعا هذه
بعض التحديات وبعض التهديدات باداره
المسجد الاقصى
هل يمكن ان تعطينا تقريبيا اعداد
المعتكفين داخل المسجد الاقصى كان ايضا
هناك اطلاق رصاص مطاطي على المعتكفين داخل
المسجد الاقصى هل هناك من اصابات هل يمكن
ان تعطينا صوره واضحه عما يجري في المسجد
الاقصى
نعمل البارحه كان عدد عدد المصلين تقريبا
80 الف حسب تقديرات مديريه شؤون الاوقاف
اليوم التقديرات كانت حوالي 20,000
ومستطاع ان يخرجون طبعا هناك هناك استخدام
للرصاص المطاطي وهناك استخدام للعنف ولكن
عدد عدد الاصابات لم تصل الى ما حدث
بالبارحه الى مئات الاصابات وخاصه القصور
واستخدام العنصر المفرط حاولوا ان يتفادوا
ان يكون هناك عدد من الاصابات او العمليات
الاعتقالات التي حدثت البارحه ايضا تجاوزت
400 عمليه اعتقال الليله لم يحدث ما حدثهم
حاولوا تجنب الاثاره
واصابه عدد كبير وحتى عمليات الاعتقالات
هناك عمليات الاعتقالات ولكن لم تصل الى
العدد الذي حدث البارحه بالنسبه حول
المسجد الاقصى ايضا ماذا يمكن ان تخبرنا
عنها
هم قرروا يقرروا اليوم لاول مره من ايام
ايام رمضان بعدم ادخال المصلين من الساعات
الصباح الباكر من الساعه السابعه حتى
الساعه الحاديه عشره ونصف وفرضوا وفرضوا
منع التائم للمصلين
الا حالات وجود بعض المصلين التي يتجاوز
عددهم 60 عام
وفرضوا ايضا قرار بمنع حتى المقدسيه من
الدخول الى الابحات المسجد الاقصى عندما
لا يتجاوز اعمارهم الخمسه واربعين سنه
طبعا هناك تطبيقات وحواجز بشكل كبير جدا
منعت من اصول اعداد كبيره كما حدث البارحه
80,000 ولكن العدد اليوم وصل تقريبا ل20
الف دخلوا قبل نهايه في المسجد القبلي حيث
يحاول ان يعتكف عدد كبير من الفلسطينيين
والمقدسين وايضا الفلسطينيين 48 ويحاول
اجهاض اي محاولات
كما حدث البارحه
طبعا هناك هناك اجراءات اكثر
لا يريدون وجود شباب بشكل اساسي وكانوا
يرفضون دخول الشباب حتى في صلوات الظهر
والعصر والمغرب والعشاء ولكن رغم كل ذلك
كان هناك اقبال اقبال تجاوز اكثر من 20
الف ولكن الان تم تفريغ تقريبا بحات
المسجد الاقصى
ولم نجد ذبحات المسجد الاقصى كما وجدناها
اليوم بين الساعه السابعه صباحا حتى
الساعه 11:30
كان كانت شبه خاليه من المسلسل للمسلمين
كان هناك فقط مستوطنين وسواحه عاديين
دكتور اشكرك ايضا الان ينضم الي ناشط
مقديسي ناصر قوس ناصر هل يمكن ان تطلعنا
على المشهد الان لديك من داخل الاقصى انت
موجود
يعني هناك محاصره للمسجد الطبلي تم اخراج
جميع
المصلين لا اريد ان اكون معتكفين لانه لم
يكن حتى في لحظه الاقتحام معتكفين كان
مصلين يؤدون صلاه التراويح ولم يكن هناك
في هذه اللحظه هو اعتكاف هو صلاه صلاه
التراويح في صلاه الوتر قاموا باستحام
المسجد القبلي
واغلق جميع الابواب وابقوا على باب واحد
من المسجد القبلي
وقاموا باخراج جميع بعد الصلاه مباشره
قاموا بدخول الى المسجد القبلي والاعتداء
على المصلين الكبار السن والشيوخ والاطفال
الذين كانوا يؤدون حتى الائمه والمؤذنين
ثم الاعتداء عليهم في اخر المسجد القبلي
واخراج جميع المصلين
نعم في اصابتين تم نقلهم الى مستشفى
المطلع قبل قليل اصابتين في الراس بسبب
القناه بالمنطقيه العيارات المطاطيه في
الراس وكان هناك اعتداء على كل المصلين في
ساحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك وقاموا
باطلاق القنابل المنطقيه وكانوا عدد
الاصابات حتى هذه اللحظه يعني تجاوز اكثر
من عشره اصابات اثنين منهم تم نقلهم الى
مستشفى المقاصد
هل سمح للهلال الاحمر بان يدخل وينقل
الجرحى
نعم لم يسمح هناك بعض الشوفان الذين
يعملون بالاسعاف عياده الاسعاف في
المسجد الاقصى تم نقلهم من المسجد
الاقصى الى منطقه باب الاصوات وتم
اخذين بطياره الاسعاف
الهلال الاحمر والدم يسمح
للسيارات اسعاف المقاصد
او هلال احمر بدخول
المسجد الاقصى لنقل الان المصابين طيب
الان حول المسجد الاقصى كيف يمكن ان تصف
لنا المشهد
يعني انا داخل المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وصحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك هناك عدد من
الشبان والمرابطات والمرابطين
يتواجدون في ساحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك
وهناك عدد كبير ايضا من جنود الاحتلال
يختصون على ابواب المسجد القبلي لا يسمحون
بدخول
الشبان ولا حتى كبار السن ولا حتى النساء
للاعدا داخل
المسجد القبلي هناك عدد كبير من قوات
الخاصه والشرطه يقفون عند باب المغاربه
وفي جميع الساحه المحيطه في المسجد القبلي
يمنعون الوصول الى المسجد القبلي محاوله
منهم لاخراج كل الشبان والنساء المتواجدين
في ساحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك اخراجهم
خارج المسجد الاقصى المبارك قام باغلاق
جميع الابواب قبل الموعد المحدد لاغلاق
ابواب المسجد الاقصى المبارك وابقوا على
باب واحد
لاخراج جميع
المصلين منه خارج ابواب المسجد الاقصى حتى
هل هناك اي اشتباكات الان في هذه اللحظات
داخل المسجد لا يوجد اشتباقات ولكن كما
علمنا ان في محيط في حراره البلد القديمه
باب العمود وسلوان هناك مواجهات مستمره
حتى هذه اللحظه بسبب اقتحام جنود الاحتلال
منذ ساعات الصباح الباكر لم تسمح للشبان
بدخول المسجد الاقصى المبارك كانت هناك
تحديدا للاعمال فوق كانت 45 ولكن بعد ذلك
صارت 60 عاما لا يستطيع قبل 60 عاما ان
يدخل الى المسجد الاقصى المبارك
يعني اعداد قليله ادت صلاه العشاء
والتراويح في المسجد الاقصى المبارك بسبب
هذه الاجراءات الاحتلاليه
الاخير عددكم الان داخل المسجد تقريبا
لا يتجاوز اكثر من 100 شخص الان يقومون
يعني الشرطه الاسرائيليه في هذه اللحظات
يقومون بالتحضير انفسهم لاخراج المصلين من
ساحات المسجد الاقصى المبارك ومن ينتشرون
في جميع المناطق الان بداوا الان الان
بداوا نعم يعني انا اتحدث معك وبداوا الان
باخراج المصلين
شكرا لك ناصر قوس النشاط المقدسي كنت مع
من داخل الاقساط
المسجد الاقصى نعم
اشكرك ناصر ساذهب الى ضيفي الان ناصر قوس
اشكرك كنت معي من داخل المسجد الاقصى كما
اشكر ايضا ضيفنا سابقا ايضا الناشط
المقدسي دكتور امجد شهاب الان سانتقل الى
ضيفه من رام الله عماد ابو عواد الخبير في
الشان الاسرائيلي استاذ عماد في اي اطار
يمكن ان نضع هذه الاقتحامات التي تتوالى
منذ الامس وحقيقه تتوالى كل سنه في شهر
رمضان المبارك
مساء الخير لك ما من شك عند الحديث عن
الاحداث الاخيره في المسجد الاقصى ممكن
وضعها في سياقين السياق الاول ما نجحت به
الحكومه الاسرائيليه خلال السنوات الاخيره
من خلال اسلوب التخدير المتعمد ومن خلال
سياسه التدرج بشكل بطيء من اجل تثبيت
معادلات في المسجد الاقصى بدات بسته الاف
مقتحم قبل عشر سنوات وصلنا الى 60 الف
مقتحم هذه الايام بدات بمنع المستوطنين من
الصلوات في المسجد الاقصى الان يسمح لهم
الصلوات في ساحات المسجد الاقصى وكذلك
محاوله ايهام الفلسطينيين والاطراف
المختلفه بان اسرائيل تحاول ضبط النفس
وتحاول الحفاظ على الواقع الموجود داخل
المسجد الاقصى عندما اظهرت اليوم الشرطه
الاسرائيليه انها منع الذبح القرابين في
المسجد الاقصى علما ان ما حدث دون ذلك
خطير وخطير جدا من الجانب الاخر لا نريد
ان ننسى بانه تشهد الاونه الاخيره ارتفاع
في ثقل الصهيونيه الدينيه التي وجد داخل
المؤسسه الاسرائيليه بشكل مهول هي بيضه
القبان في الحكومه الاسرائيليه يتبعها
اكثر من يعني اكثر من خمسين جمعيه
استطانيه سواء داخل المدينه المقدسه او في
مستوطنات الضفه الغربيه تعمل فقط تحت
عنوان بناء الهيكل مكان المسجد الاقصى هذا
التزاوج ما بين الامرين بات يقود بشكل
كبير الى عمل الشرطه الاسرائيليه التي جزء
كبير منها الان يتبنى الفكر الكاهنوتي
وينتمي الى الصهيونيه الدينيه
ذهبت باتجاه الايمان بضروره تطبيق الرؤيه
الدينيه الكهنوتيه التي تقول بانه يجب ان
يكون هناك تقسيم زماني ومن ثم تقسيم مكاني
في المسجد الاقصى واريد ان اذكر هنا بانه
حتى قبل 20 عاما
عن تقديم مكاني ترفض اقتحام المسجد الاقصى
لكن اليوم تسمح بذلك نعم
يعني كنت ذكرت عن التقسيم الزماني التقسيم
الزماني حاصل منذ سنوات نتحدث الان عن
تقسيم مكاني
بالتاكيد التقسيم الزماني كما نشاهد يعني
على سبيل المثال اليوم تم اخراج كل
المصلين المسلمين مساحات المسجد الاقصى
بحدود تقريبا الساعه الثامنه صباحا ثم
بدات لمده اكثر من ساعتين اقتحامات
المستوطنين برعايه الشرطه الاسرائيليه
والغريب ان جزء من هؤلاء الشرطه كانوا
يؤدي بعض الصلوات التلميذيه معه اولى
المستوطنين بالتالي معالم التقسيم الزماني
باتت واضحه بشكل كبير وبالمناسبه الشعار
التي ترفع الصهيونيه الدينيه والذي يرفع
ايتامار هو هذا الشعار بانه هذا المكان
المقدس يجب ان يكون فيه حريه عباده لكل
الاديان بمعنى ان اسرائيل حتى تحاول تثبيت
ذلك من خلال الخطاب الناعم هنا وهناك
تحديدا لدى الاروقه المختلفه سواء في
الاقليم او المؤسسات الدوليه شكرا لك من
رام الله عماد ابو عواد الخبير في الشان
الاسرائيلي
المشاهدين توتر غير مسبوق شهدته الاراضي
الفلسطينيه بعد مهاجمه الشرطه الاسرائيليه
المصلين في المسجد الاقصى حيث الشبكه
الشرطه الاسرائيليه مع عشرات من المصلين
الفلسطينيين زعمه انها نفذت المداهمه بعد
التحصن من وصفتهم بالمحرضين داخل المسجد
ورشقهم للشرطه بالمفرقعات الناريه والعصي
والحجاره وقالت الشرطه في بيان لها انها
اعتقلت وابعدت اكثر من 350 شخصا كما قصفت
طائرات اسرائيليه مواقع في قطاع غزه عقب
اطلاق صواريخ من القطاع باتجاه اسرائيل
اما بالنسبه لردود الفعل العربي على
الاقتحام الاسرائيلي للاقصى عبرت المملكه
العربيه السعوديه عن رفضها القاطع لهذه
الممارسات التي تقود جهود السلام وتتعارض
مع المبادئ والاعراف الدوليه اما في عمان
استنكرت وزاره الخارجيه الاردنيه باشد
العبارات اقدام الشرطه الاسرائيليه على
اقتحام المسجد بدورها شجبت وزاره الخارجيه
المصريه هذه الاعتداءات التي ادت الى وقوع
اصابات عديده بين المصلين والمعتكفين بمن
فيهم النساء كذلك طلبه الجامعه العربيه
مجلس الامن بدفع اسرائيل لوقف التصعيد في
الاماكن المقدسه
في ذات السياق اعرب الامين العام للامم
المتحده انطونيو عن صدمته وذهوله ازاء
مستوى العنف الذي استخدمته قوات الامن
الاسرائيليه بحق مصلين فلسطينيين داخل
المسجد الاقصى وقال ستيفانك المتحدث باسم
ان الامين العام شاهد صور العنف والضرب
داخل الموقع المقدس حيث وصف الوضع بالمحزن
والماساوي
البيت الابيض عبر عن قلقه من تطورات
الاحداث في المسجد الاقصى وشدد على ضروره
خفض التصعيد بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين وقال المتحدث باسم مجلس
الامن القومي في البيت الابيض جون كوربي
انه من الضروري ان يعمل كل من
الاسرائيليين والفلسطينيين معا لتهدئه هذا
التوتر واستعاده الهدوء واضاف بان البيت
الابيض يحس
الاطراف لتجنب المزيد من التصعيد والتوتر
[موسيقى]
فاصل قصير ونواصل بعده اخبار الساعه بقوا
معنا
[موسيقى]
الان في اخبار الساعه ننتقل الى الشان
الروسي الاوكراني حيث اتهمت المتحدثه باسم
الخارجيه الروسيه ماريا زخا روفا الدول
الغربيه بمحاوله فتح جبهه جديده ضدها من
جورجيا في المقابل قال وزير الخارجيه
الامريكي انتوني بلينكن ان بوتين فشل في
تحقيق اهدافه باوكرانيا مشددا على اصرار
بلاده بدعم اوكرانيا حتى تتمكن من الدفاع
عن نفسها
من جهته قال الرئيس
بان اجهزه مخابرات غربيه ضالعه فيما وصفه
باعمال تخريبيه وارهابيه نفذتها اوكرانيا
في روسيا وفي اجتماعه مع مجلس الامن
الروسي اتهم بوتين اوكرانيا بارتكاب جرائم
ضد مسؤولين الروس وجنود في قوات الامن
وصحفيين ومدرسين بمساعده اجهزه المخابرات
الغربيه
غادر ممثله عدد من الدول الاعضاء في مجلس
الامن الاجتماعا دعت اليه روسيا بشان
اوكرانيا عند ظهور المفوضه الروسيه لشؤون
الطفوله ماريا الفوفا بيلوفا عبر الفيديو
يذكر ان بيلوفا اصدرت المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه مذكره توقيف بحقها في وقت تتهم
السلطات الاوكرانيه موسكو بخطف اكثر من 16
الف طفل من اوكرانيا منذ بدء الهجوم
الروسي قبل عام
حلموا اتمام السيطره على المناطق التي
دخلتها القوات الروسيه في اوكرانيا تنسجه
موسكو منذ شهور ان لم يكن سنوات خلايا
نائمه من الجواسيس الروس كشفتها السلطات
الاوكرانيه هؤلاء جندهم الكريم حربه ثم
قياده الدوله بعد احكام السيطره من اعضاء
الخليه زوجان كانايا يعيشان في مدينه
اوديسا الساحليه لسنوات اذا عثرت عثرت
السلطات الاوكرانيه في شقتهما اثناء
تفتيشها على هاتف يحتوي على محادثه مع رجل
يعيش في شبه جزيره القرم وهو من قدام
المحاربين في الجيش الروسي
الحديث عن الجواسيس الروس في اوكرانيا
يفتح الباب امام ملف اوسع وهو الجواسيس
الروس النائمون الذين تحدثت عنهم الصحيفه
تايمز البريطانيه وقالت انها شبكه تنكشف
شيئا فشيئا في اوروبا تناولت التقرير
كيفيه تخفيهم وسرد قصص مع بعضهم الى جانب
السبب في زياده النشاط الغربي في التعرف
عليهم حاليا من قصص هؤلاء الجواسيس اورد
التقرير ان شابا البرازيليا يدعى فيكتور
مولر فيريرا حاصل على درجات الماجستير من
احدى جامعات امريكا وصل الى مطار شيفرول
بامستردام
لتلقي تدريب داخلي في المحكمه الجنائيه
الدوليه في لهايه لكن الامور لم تسر وفقا
لما خطط له مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
الامريكي كان ابلغ السلطات الهولنديه ان
هذا الشاب ليس برازيليا بل هو ضابط في
المخابرات العسكريه الروسيه واسمه شركه
بعد ذلك تمت اعادته الى ساو باولو حيث حكم
عليه بالسجن 15 عاما بتهمه انتحال الهويه
كما ورد التقرير قصه الروسيه ميخائيل
ميكوتشين الذي يخضع للاستجوار في النرويج
منذ اكتوبر الماضي بتهمه كونه ضابطا في
المخابرات العسكريه الروسيه ويتنكروا في
شخصيه امريكي جنوبي
التقرير اشار الى ان مثل هؤلاء النائمين
الذين يتخذونه ويا مزوره على مدى فتره
طويله من الزمن كانوا على مدى عقود سمه من
سمات التجسس السوفيتي مضيفا انهم يدخلون
في البلد المستهدف لكنهم يقضون سنوات لدمج
انفسهم في المجتمع ولا يصبحون نشطين على
الفور
بالنسبه لاوكرانيا القوات الروسيه باتت
على اهبه الاستعداد لصد هجوم الاوكراني
محتمل خلال الاسابيع القليله المقبله اذ
تعمل القوات الروسيه على تعزيز دفاعاتها
في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها في جنوب
اوكرانيا عبر زرع حقول الغام وبناء حواجز
وخنادق بحسب تقرير صحيفه نيويورك تايمز
وبدات القوات الروسيه في حفر حواجز
الدفاعيه بين حدود مناطق زفوريجيا دونياس
وخيرسون بالاضافه الى خط دفاعي في مدينه
تتوقع ان يمنع الهجوم الاوكرانيه المحتمل
على منطقه زافوريجيا القوات الروسيه من
مواصله قصفها شبه المستمر لمدينه خيسون
والبلدات والقرى القريبه من ضفه نهر في
الشرق
لكن مشاهدينا وبالرغم من استمرار اكياز
بالاستعداد لهجومها القادم تسابق ساحات
القتال المساعد الدبلوماسيه الجاريه من
اجل وقف الصراع التجري الجهودها على قدم
وساق في اوكرانيا فيما اكد بعض القاده
العسكريين الاوكران ان الهجوم التي تستعد
له باتا وشيكا
[موسيقى]
حيث صرح الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد
ترامب عبر منصه التروس انه يجب على
الجمهوريين في الكونجرس الغاء تمويل وزاره
العدل ومكتب التحقيقات الفيدرالي حتى
يعودوا لرشدهم كما اضاف ترامب ان
الديمقراطيين استخدموا النظام القانوني
كالسلاح ولن يسمح الشعب بذلك الرئيس
السابق اشار ايضا الى ان كل المحللين
القانونيين والسياسيين اكدوا له ان تهم
الجائر بحقه ليست متينه وان تلك التهم
ليست جريمه
[تصفيق]
خرج كالمنتصر امس من المحكمه في نيويورك
رغم اربعه بل 34 تهمه تواجهه ليلف حوله
مناصريه ويهاجم متهميه لكن الرئيس
الامريكي سابق دونالد ترامب بالفعل ربح
بعدها بساعات دعوا قضائيه ضد الممثله
ستورميدانيز حيث قضت محكمه الاستئناف
كاليفورنيا بان تدفع دانييلز مبلغ 120 الف
دولار لترامب لقاء اتعاب المحاماه في دعوه
تشير التي اقامتها ضده وخسرتها ليكون
اجمالي المبلغ الذي ستدفعه دانيلز لترامب
حوالي 600 الف دولار لقاء الرسومي
القانونيه والاستئناف الاخر
اذا بعد متول الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب امام المحكمه الجنائيه في
منهاتن امس وجهت الترامب لائحه اتهامات من
اربعه وثلاثين بندا دفع الاخير ببراءته
منها جميعا قبل ان يغادر قاعه المحكمه بعد
انتهاء الجلسه الا ان هناك مفقودات وفقا
لتقرير نشرته صحيفه
فما هو المفقود اذا في لائحه اتهام ترامب
المدعي العام يقول ان الرئيس السابق قام
مرارا وتكرارا بتزوير سجلات تجاريه من
الدرجه الاولى وايضا هناك تهمه رئيسيه
اخرى تتعلق بشراء صمت صمت ب130 الف دولار
دفعها مساعد ترامب السابق مايكل كوهان
لاسكات ستور ميدانيلز بشان علاقتها
المزعومه مع الرئيس الا انها جميعها تهم
فرديه فالسؤال الكبير الذي بقي دون اجابه
هو اين هي الجريمه الثانيه فتزوير السجلات
التجاريه يعد جنحه في نيويورك لان ترامب
استعان للسداد بيكهان كمال جريمه الاخرى
التي يزعم انه يحاول التستر عليها كانت
النظريه الرئيسيه التي تم طرحها الثلاثاء
هي ان السيد براج يدعي بان ترامب قام
بانتهاك قوانين تمويل الحملات الانتخابيه
الا ان كهان اعترف فعلا بما قام به ما جعل
الامر غير قابل للنقاش
[موسيقى]
في اخبار الساعه سنتابع بعض لحظات
يستيقظ من سباته فهل يتحول الى جائحه
[موسيقى]
نتابع مشاهدينا من ملف زياره الرئيس
الفرنسي الى الصين يبدو ان باريس
حضورها على الساحه الدوليه فالى جانب
تقديم نفسها طرفا فاعلا في الملفات
المختلفه وخاصه ان الزياره تاتي في وقت
تتصاعد فيه حده الازمات بين فكين والغرب
زياره ماكرون بدات اليوم وستمتد لثلاثه
ايام برفقه رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه
تحت شعار الوحده الاوروبيه شرط اساسي
لبناء شراكه متوازنه مع الصين ويسحب
الرئيس الفرنسي ايضا عشرات الخبراء
الاقتصاديين والرؤساء الشرك الشركات
الفرنسيه بهدف دعوه الشركات الصينيه
لزياده استثماراتها في فرنسا ودول الاتحاد
ولفح مجال الاستثمار في الصين في مثال
الزياره راى مكروه انه يمكن لبيكين ان
تلعب دورا رئيسيا لايجاد طريق يؤدي الى
السلام في اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا اثرت بشكل عميق على النظام
الدولي وانتهكت ميثاق الامم المتحده
الحرب التي قادتها روسيا في اوكرانيا بشكل
عميق على النظام الدولي الذي عرفناه منذ
عام
1945 هذه الحرب التي وصفتها مرارا وتكرارا
بانها امبرياليه واستعماريه انتهكت العديد
من مبادئ ميثاق الامم المتحده والتي يجب
علينا الدفاع عنها بحزم لذا يمكن للصين
على وجه التحديد ان تلعب دورا رئيسيا
ومن خلال هذه الزياره يمكن استشراف
الطريقه التي تقيم بها فرنسا علاقتها
بالصين الدرجه الاولى تكمن في التباين مع
واشنطن حول الصين حيث ان وجهه النظر
الفرنسيه في التعاطي مع الصين ما زالت
تختلف عن وجهه النظر الامريكيه والدليل
عدم اقتناع باريس بجدول خطاب الامريكي
المتمثل في وضع الصين وروسيا ضمن سله
الانظمه الاستبداديه الى جانب ترحيب باريس
بالخطه الصينيه لتحقيق السلام في اوكرانيا
اما الدرجه الثانيه تكمن بتشجيع الصين على
القيام بوساطه في اوكرانيا بطلب من مكرون
الرئيس الصيني تشينج في قمه مجموعه
العشرين في بالي خلال نوفمبر 2022
هدف باريس ايضا الضغط على الصين من اجل
عدم ارسال الاسلحه الى روسيا اذ سيحاول
مكرو ابلاغ نظيره الصيني بان اوروبا لن
تقبل بان تقدم بكين سلاحا صينيا لاستخدامه
على الاراضي الاوروبيه هدف اخر في اجنده
ماكرون يكمن بوقف التلويح الروسي باستخدام
الاسلحه النوويه مع العلم ان الصين تبنت
فكره تقليص الاخطار الاستراتيجيه وعدم
استخدام الاسلحه النوويه وتجنب خوض حروب
نوويه
[موسيقى]
لا علاج له مميت وخطير وسريع الانتشار
نتحدث عن فيروس مارفل الذي يثير انتشاره
حاله من الفزع عالميا فهو يتسبب بحمى
نصفيه شديده العدوى بحسب مراكز السيطره
على الامراض الامريكيه سي دي سي وهو من
عائله فيروس بولا وكلاهما لديه القدره على
التسبب في معدلات وفيات عاليه بين
المصابين الصحه العالميه قالت ان معدلات
الوفيات بين المصابين بفيروس مارفل تتراوح
بين 24 الى 88 بالمئه وفقا لحالات
الانتشار السابقه واتعرف العلماء لاول مره
على هذا الفيروس عام 1967 عندما انتشر بين
عمال المختبرات في مارج وفرانكفورت
بالمانيا وفي بيل جراد اثناء اجراء البحوث
على حيوانات استوردت من اوغندا
ورغم ان هذا الفيروس لا ينتقل عبر الهواء
فانه ينتشر بسرعه من خلال الاتصال المباشر
بين البشر خاصه المرتبطين بالسوائل مثل
الدم او اللعاب او البول ويمكن حتى لجثث
المصابين ان تبقى معديه عند الدفع ووفقا
لمنظمه الصحه العالميه تقدر فتره الحضانه
للاصابه بالفيروس بين ثلاثه الى تسعه ايام
وتبدا اعراضه بالاصابه بصداع حاد ووعك
شديده والام عضليه تشمل ايضا حمى شديده
اسهال حاد والم في البطن وغثيان وتقيؤ
يمكن ان يدوم اسبوعا استمرار الاصابه تؤدي
الى اصابه الجهاز العصبي في الحالات
المميته وتحدث الوفاه في اليوم الثامن او
التاسع
يرى معظم المختصين ان الوقايه بشكل عام من
الحمى النزفيه
المرتبطه بالفيروسات مثل
قد تكون امرا صعبا اذا كنت تعيش في مناطق
تنتشر فيها هذه الامراض او تسافر لها
وعليك استخدام وسائل وقايه عند التعامل مع
اي من سوائل الجسم بارتداء قفازات وواقيات
العين والوجه كما يجب تجنب الحشرات خاصه
البعوض والقراض وعليك ارتداء السراويل
الطويله والاكمام الطويله واستخدام وسائل
الحمايه من البعوض كما عليك ابعاد القوارض
عن منزلك بوضع القمامه في حاويات مضاده
للقوارض والتخلص من النفايات بانتظام
واحرص على ان يكون للابواب والنوافذ وقيات
حشرات
واذا كانت الوقايه صعبه فالعلاج لم يعتمد
بعد بل يعتمد ويتلقى المصابون الرعايه
الداعمه وعلاجات للمضاعفات والجفاف تعمل
على تحسين معدلات البقاء على قيد الحياه
وفق منظمه الصحه العالميه
اشكر لكم طيب المتابعه اترككم في امان
الله
[موسيقى]